this is a production of cornell
university
uh anyhow so i'm really happy to be here
today it's been nice to see all uh as uh
carlin mentioned i retired at the end of
january i've sort of been rooting around
my house for the month of february and
trying to figure out what to do next and
that's still a work in progress
but i wanted to talk
and
i also note that i'm the third retiree
or soon-to-be retiree to give us talk
this semester
so it seems like it's a trend
i don't know next year we might have
what five or six or
anyhow
it just does underline me that we're in
this time of transition
so um so i wanted to talk about uh uh
you know my view of extension and uh
instead of going through a blow by blow
of my retrospective of my career just
talk about
different models that people use for
extension and how is it that growers
adopt practices what what what are the
impacts uh that we we
make uh so in the interest of full
disclosure i want to say that this is a
rerun
and i gave this uh almost this exact
talk about five years ago up at uh
agritech
and uh so it was great to have that
skeleton
here for my uh for my talk today
so i just want to start out a little bit
with my my history
and uh i came to cornell in 1985 to be
an entomology a graduate student i just
come off the peace corps in honduras
and uh was eager to continue my
education i worked with john and ira
as my advisor and then
finally they let me have a phd
and i got to shake hands with frank
rhodes
the president of cornell at that time
uh following that i spent five years
working in grape entomology
a lot of that time i was with working on
this one insect the eastern grape leaf
hopper i got to know that sucker well in
five years
but by the end of that it sort of felt
kind of narrow so it was a disciplinary
focus
and it was just on
grape grape insects
so when the opportunity came to apply
for the
finger lakes grape program area
education
extension educator job i i jumped in
and i got that job uh
and i have to say that initially i
thought i'm an entomologist i know about
bugs i've never grown a grapevine in my
life
so what is it
exactly that i have to offer these
people because they've been growing
great for four or five generations in
certain cases
uh but i soon found out that
they weren't expecting me to be the guy
that knows how to fill up a sprayer or
exactly prune grapes like like they
could
uh and that was a
that might be the most wonderful
extension job in new york
actually
uh so i did that for nine years uh it
was based in penang
and then i moved back to the station or
cornell agritech as we call it now as
senior extension associate
uh to start this uh statewide
viticulture extension program
and uh carlin's already mentioned some
of the things i did and i'll highlight a
few more things as i go along
uh so this has been a great run for me
it's been so much fun
uh
being in the position i'm i'm in
so what i wanted to
address
today is well what is it
that growers do with our research
you know
what changes do they make how do we know
that they're making change
and how do funding agencies know what
changes they're making
and this is important because funding
funders are increasingly interested in
metrics you know how do you know
and i'll go through a couple funding
models
uh in in in a minute
uh so here's my
five key takeaways from extension and
the way i ran my extension program
so first of all
uh
my feeling is that the on-farm research
and demonstration projects are
kind of the key
i always view that as
my first job
i wasn't there to solve problems for
people necessarily to take calls
uh to tell people what to spray so that
gets to the second point is that
extension
some people think it's about being a
consultant
but it's not about telling growers what
to do it's
it's about
learning
i'll get to that in a moment again so
generating explaining data is the thing
that sets us aside from
consultants and people who tell growers
what to do
so that's
kind of our super power
is that we have
access to data we
we generate it
and
this is news to funders but change
doesn't generally happen
within the life of a single project
you know it's more gradual than that
and finally it really pays to be
opportunistic
uh so i want to go through a couple of
models
so
i think our standard thing that we you
know i grew up with
is that you have the researchers
they're the ones that generate the
knowledge they pass it on to extension
to disseminate the knowledge the growers
adopt the practices
and then it's kind of like a little
package that you deliver to them
and
so this approach really emphasizes
you know define the project
the problem
uh test hypothesis do an experimental
design get the results
and then at the end you get this
statement which i've seen in so many
grant proposals
that
results will be disseminated through
winter conferences etc how many of you
pis have written that in grant proposals
yeah
me too
and then i've been
listed on
many many more grant proposals that say
exactly that
so that's kind of the standard model
uh
and uh
a while back uh we came along probably
about 20 years ago it came along this uh
this outcome-driven project model
and uh that was championed with uh
new york farm viability institute the
northeast sarah
program
and uh this guy r david smith who was
the associate director of
cornell cooperative extension is the guy
behind
disseminating this model and getting
these organizations to adopt it
so here's how that goes first you start
out with grower defined barriers and
opportunities you know you get growers
together saying yeah what are your
problems they set goals you have
performance targets and then milestones
and activities and it's all pointed out
to the outcomes that you want right
so x number growers adopt practices
save y amount of money or generate
z economic impact
so this is a fine model but
when i wrote these proposals and i did
several of them
i found myself in the middle of it
saying
damn it you know i just want to test
these three treatments and see what
happens
and
this model doesn't say anything
necessarily about the knowledge itself
or the things that you learn it's more
about how people
uh react to it
so
where's the science
and
so that model sort of
goes like this you expose 500 growers to
this practice
you receive training
and then
30 rows adopt it and uh
and then these are the things that come
out of it
metrics success stories outcomes
interesting they never asked for failure
stories right
i tried something that didn't
it didn't work
so it's still the packet at the end
and here's an example uh this is from
a few years ago the farm liabilities
website and they say well
you know it's not all about the hours
they clock in research fact sheets etc
it's about
what people do
uh
to this so you're supposed to again
measure these metrics have the success
stories and then the outcomes okay
uh and i have an example of that this is
a project we did
2006 to 2008 we put together this
comprehensive sustainable practices
workbook called vine balance
i did this with members of the industry
it's really comprehensive it covers pest
management
viticulture spray technology etc etc
uh so it covers a wide range of things
but here's sort of the bottom line
in this again is off the farm viability
website
is that
what it came down to is the only metrics
we could come up with was
nitrogen use so
so they invested 148 000 in the
uh
in the project
uh
we reported that growers reduced
nitrogen applications by 40
percent and here's the return on
investment
well that's just one aspect of something
where everything else if it's about
sustainability it's a little bit harder
to measure because it's about grower
relations it's about
community it's about
environmental quality so how do you put
a dollar figure on that
it's harder than
something i can do
so here's how i think it
actually works or should work
we have
growers researchers extension
all kind of communicating with each
other the researchers bring the
disciplinary focus
extension brings a generalist focus
and then come up with ideas and
questions trials
you know
that can be laboratory and field trials
collaborative on-farm demos and then you
have the results but you're also
communicating during the project and
then growers try something and then they
adapt it right and then it goes back
so
so really
it's definitely not a package it's more
of a
more of a process basically
uh so i want to offer several uh
examples of things where
we know that growers have really changed
their practices
and then i'm gonna go on and talk about
some
field trials and sort of the impacts so
here's one that dave ghidori did
in the early 2000s
he took some
powdery mildew and
inoculated clusters at various times
and kind of overturned the prevailing
uh
thought about
how to keep your clusters clean from
powdery mildew and later on donnie
mildew
so
before he did this people thought well
they're susceptible that the entire
summer and until they're until you get
reach uh eight eight degrees bricks when
they start ripening so you gotta keep it
things on well he found that they
actually became resistant much earlier
uh so you know four to six weeks after
bloom
uh then you could be sure that if your
clusters were clean they they're gonna
stay clean
and uh so this has been a cornerstone uh
this is
stuff that wayne wilcox wrote and
so
uh we really emphasize a pre-bloom to
early post-bloom
uh
sprays
you know for the times when the grapes
are most susceptible and so forth and
then after that you can sort of ease off
uh on the on the things
uh directed at the clusters
so again this is a cornerstone of our
ipm program is this
uh another one is uh involved justine
vandenheuvel and gavin sachs
and it was all about leaf removal and
when you should do it right
and uh before they did this study
people knew that leaf removal was
important that cluster exposure was
important
but they just sort of say well you know
i'm gonna do it when i get get around to
it and you know
you know sometime you know mid-summer or
something well uh gavin
uh a wine chemist
went out in the vineyard every week
collected samples measured
methoxypyrazines and found out that the
cluster exposure very early in the
season really had a big impact on how
many of these
methoxy piercings were produced and
therefore how many of them that you
ended up with at the end of the season
so
uh so that
alerted people to the fact that the
early leaf removal was important
and uh and it really changed practices
it went from
i'll do it when i get around to it to
god i better get out there and do that
because it's so important
so we wrote this up in the first issue
of appalachian cornell in this article
called
cornell researchers track
tackle
green flavors and red wines
uh
andrew landers uh was here for about 15
years or so before he
left and he's back in
england but his spray trials uh you know
sprayer set up using deflectors etc etc
i always used to joke with him that
every talk could be about improving
deposition and reducing drift
uh because that's what he contemplated
so he had set up this patternator you
know
one of his many demonstrations at field
meetings
and then uh he did collaborate with uh
uh jim myers and then
justine vandenhuvel
were able to quantify through this thing
called the epqa
enhanced
point quadrant analysis
that the spray coverage you know really
was
uh highly dependent on
the fruit
uh exposure
uh
and uh so
this grower bill del ripple took took it
upon himself to build one of these
patternators
out of window screens and uh
so here's an example of a grower
taking something that was designed for
research and
applying it to their own vineyard so he
built it for
what 50 50 bucks and he says in
15 minutes i can run my sprayer and
find out you know how how the spray is
being
distributed and make adjustments thereby
okay
uh this is a little bit more long term
and this is our nitrogen use guidelines
when i started i talked to growers
in 97 and they say oh yeah 300 pounds
ammonium nitrate 100 pounds actual
nitrogen per acre you know and i can't
afford to skimp on this
it's cheap insurance
you hear that a lot
uh but nelson schallis uh
1960s established this experiment called
the west tier factorial i can't get into
details about it but found out that you
know no matter how much nitrogen they
applied
you know if it was above 50 pounds
they only got a little extra volume
growth
and uh no extra yield
so
um so he was able to say you know 50
pounds that's
that's it so uh
you know that went through bob poole
terry bates and uh my predecessor dave
peterson started talking about this in
maybe the 1980s early 80s
and then i carried on and pretty soon i
talked to growers at
coffee shops i said well
how much are you putting on this year
well
oh i backed it off to 70 pounds
next year 50 pounds
and of course many of our vinifera
growers don't apply any additional
nitrogen at all so
so this is a big
big success and
this is what we cited in our farm
viability grant but uh you know 30 to 50
percent reduction in
nitrogen application or excess nitrogen
application
okay so i want to move on now to some
examples of on-farm trials
and the first one is field trials that
educate me you know being an
entomologist not having any background
in nutrition or not that much in
horticulture
and then surveys
to gauge how important an issue was
demonstrations that happened alongside
research trials
and then sort of serendipity how one
thing turned into something else and
then and then i want to finish it off
with a
project that's had an enormous economic
impact but it's based on stuff that was
started in the 60s and
and moved on with our concord growers
so
my first example is effective foliar and
soil
uh
boron applications and uh
you know i mean i was an entomologist
this was early on in my career i didn't
know anything about boron
so i decided to do this trial with kind
of a a guy who's kind of a back bencher
you know he doesn't really go to
meetings he doesn't
so but he had a low boron vineyard and
so we set up a trial there and compared
you know soil and no soil and different
rates to foliar sprays
so here's the results and this is you
know like the
second year or the first year of my uh
extension
uh found out that the soil and foliar
application increased the yield burst in
his vineyard increased a fruit set but
one pound of foliar was as good as you
know two and a half pounds
and two and a half pounds all often
resulted in fourier
uh injury
um
so
this is the pedial results and the
foliar increased patio more on more than
the soil but two and a half pounds again
was too much and one was
enough
and then
the boron
levels dropped in august when we sampled
again but
but not as much with the soil
application so that gave more sustained
release of warren it was important
so i put that in my newsletter and uh
and that gave me the confidence to be
able to make recommendations to growers
about boron
and i think hadn't had an impact
again how do we measure it
uh next example i want to uh
relate has to do with uh
wine balance our important
thing and uh
and uh
so this is an opportunistic thing that
was made possible because alan laxo
retired
he had a vineyard up at the station
and nobody was going to take it over so
i did and that gave me an opportunity to
do some really radical things
and run that vineyard into the ground
which i did over the next several years
uh
okay and and this is something where you
know
i had done all the reading and but i
really wanted to experience
what happens when you manipulate carbon
source and sink
things
so
uh
again you know the source being the leaf
area the sinks or the carbohydrates
that are produced you know going to
different places shoot tips fruit roots
storage and so forth
so
i decided to do this experiment to
radically manipulate these things
in uh in that vineyard
uh
and i wanted to measure how particularly
how defoliating vines affected the bud
hardiness because that's the sort of a
thing
is that uh
uh you want to maximize the bud
hardiness but what happens when you get
downing mill to late in the season you
lose all your foliage etc
okay so i i'm not going to tell you
everything about this but we established
five treatments we had a standard one
with 24 shoots
we had one where we
limited it to eight shoots we defrosted
some vines and then we defoliated
you know
one time and two times
lines
uh
not exactly what i'd planned but you
know here we go the standard was
supposed to be balance cropping
you know eight shoots under cropped
uh defruited no crop
uh
sink limited
and then uh overcropped and source
limited
with a high
fruit full or
really
uh
infinite fruit to foliage
uh ratio so this is uh what we did we
defoliated vines in early in july by
august they'd uh regrow grown
uh a complete other canopy
and so we
then
sort of cut them off at the tenth node
and uh and let those vines continue to
ripen the fruit continue to ripen
without any leaves whatsoever
so here's the results in a nutshell
so the standard is on the left uh if we
look at the eight chute
we reduced the yield by sixty percent uh
uh but increased the cluster weight by
forty percent so you know the clusters
were forty percent bigger
of course there were far fewer of them
which is accounts for all the yield loss
uh defoliated them once at fruit set we
got really tiny berries
had the same number of clusters but our
yield went down by 60 percent our
cluster weight by
uh by 40 percent
and then uh but the fruit ripened
because we had another canopy there
and then when we defoliated it again you
know we lost the yield
minus 60 cluster weight down by 50
percent and of course these grapes
didn't ripen at all
and
and then the buds were not as hardy this
is the only treatment we had that
affected the bud hardiness negatively
and a lot of those vines died so i ran
them into the ground
uh okay so so um
so that's one of the things those are
the two things i did to
find out well how far can i push things
one one way or another you know what
impact do our practices have
and i could do that at a the experiment
station because i didn't have to worry
about
the problem
uh the third example i have is a survey
that we did about grapevine leaf roll uh
so we wanted to survey the vineyards to
measure the extent
and uh
impact and this all started out with
mark fuchs
um
i bruce
who came and uh
shortly after he came to cornell started
looking at vineyards and we found a lot
of leaf roll this is uh limburger four
rosa limberger with the leaf roll
symptoms
and uh
very prevalent and i was later to find
out that all the limburger wood came
from one source and it was all infected
with leaf roll in about 10 vineyards and
the fender lakes
so we did this survey
and mark did this
several locations uh i think about 70
vineyards that we did
and uh we found out that uh it was
indeed very common seventy percent of
our vineyards uh vinifera vineyards had
uh at least some leaf roll some a lot
some not so much
you know hybrid varieties you know about
57 of them i had had a
different leaf oil
so my part oh okay excuse me and then
mark
measured the spread and found out that
year over year
uh this uh these mealybugs at the top of
the screen that you can see
um really
would transmit it from vine divine
within the uh
the vineyard
so my part was to go to
a vineyard where i knew there was some
infected and some non-infected or
non-symptomatic vines
and do periodic fruit sampling
so i did this and uh you know basically
the upshot was we found out that uh
at least in terms of bricks
uh
it delayed ripening by about two weeks
which is a problem with cabernet franc
when you harvest it in the middle of
october anyhow
so essentially
the infected vines were never getting
the fruit was never getting ripe on them
so that's in the single vineyard i then
you know follow that up with looking at
paired vines in different uh vineyards
in 11 different vineyards and found out
you know at a given time
uh
up to three and a half degrees bricks
difference between the
infected and non-infected vine and this
was after 2004 when we lost a lot of
vines due to uh winter injury
and uh here's a you know and they'd
plant new vines and they'd be infected
so here they've lost a vine and then a
couple years later they find out that
their replants are infected with virus
and
they have to go and replace them again
so
um so this uh really convinced a lot of
growers to pay attention to leaf roll
and we put this all in this uh
article
uh about grapevine leaf roll
and then that was followed up uh with uh
and mark
enlisted miguel gomez and operators to
do an economic analysis of lethal
and he went beyond what economists
usually do
you know what economists usually do is
say well this cost the industry x
millions of dollars but they went
through and they did different
management scenarios and a net present
value analysis to show
if you actually
did different management where you'd end
up
so he came up with a figure that uh of
you know probably ten thousand dollars
an acre over the 25 year
uh life of the vineyard
okay uh here's one with uh another one
with justine
uh who again just after she arrived
started some uh different trials with
canopy management and this one was about
uh shoot thinning uh with
marichelle fosh
and uh so
she did a study where she did
control versus
unshoot thin versus shoot then early
harvest and late harvest and then
did some wine sensory analysis on that
uh and this gets to the point of well
how much does it cost and how much is
the benefit so i went out with these
guys one day and timed them as they were
kind of going at slow walking speeds
doing the
the shoot thing
and you know about 15 seconds per vine
that uh translates to three hours an
acre 50 50 bucks but then they lose crop
too so
they're reducing the crop while thinning
the shoots so that's 750 dollars in
lower seats so to make this pay
essentially you have to you need to get
an extra 800 an acre in quality
whether that's being able to sell your
grapes or
have higher priced wine as opposed to
planck
right
and then uh here's a timing issue if you
wait until the shoots are that long it's
gonna take you
five times as long to do so this is uh
steve lurch justine's uh
technician that
was a little late on a study that
justine was doing that year
okay so what did justine find
uh well she found that and this is
compared to the control you know where
they harvested early they didn't shoot
then
just doing the shoot thinning increased
some of the good stuff fruit banana
apple rose
decreased some of the bad stuffs
uh
so that had an effect just the shoot
thing
uh just harvesting them a week later had
a big effect
uh kind of comparable
and if you did them both together it was
kind of an added additive effect
so these are interesting uh results
um and then she measured you know
revenue
and uh costs
and figured out that the grower would
have to receive you know 161 dollar more
a ton to actually pay for you know
pay for that thinning
in terms of the lost yield or 22 cents a
bottle or 31 cents a bottle so that's
fine
um
so
about a year after she did that i
decided to go out and do
demo trials in eight different vineyards
mostly hires and i'm not going to go
through this whole table but
you know 18 to 42 seconds per vine
half a ton to 3.3 tons per acre
you know differences in lost yield and
quality and then we did see
a very consistent uh bricks effect
uh so this is a one notable thing where
we actually made wines out of these so
this is a block called the leon mio
down on keuka lake and you can see the
difference between the clusters there
uh unthinned on the left thin on the
right
a totally different cluster shape
in
set
so
what happened in this well um
we reduced the shoots providing clusters
provide crop weight tons per acre by
about 30 to you know almost 50 percent
but increase the cluster weight the
berry weight and the berries per cluster
also increase the bricks so came up with
higher quality fruit right
okay so if we look at uh you know he was
getting 800 per ton
so we figured that with the amount we'd
send off in this low yielding vineyard
he'd need an extra 300 per ton
or 50
50 cents a bottle
for the price
so that goes a certain way but
uh the problem was that this is a highly
prized wine without chute thinning i
went for 20 bucks a bottle
and if he had one and you know a ton
less fruit per acre that translates to
831 fewer bottles of wine to sell
and 16 000
lower gross receipts
so
uh
so in this case you know he can sell all
he wants
and the quality
the extra quality he gets probably
doesn't matter
uh
and i'm going to skip over this this
just shows so we did the same thing on
tremonet
but it was a
lower proportion of the yield and really
it only made a 90
difference per ton for equal returns or
13 cents
so highly cultivar dependent and yield
dependent
so uh here's uh what you know the wine
evaluation said for justine's project
yeah they like the shoot thin wine
you know they found it was different
than the control and they preferred it
over the control right
so that's one result
uh and i did with the leon mio we went
uh to the rape growers convention and
did side by side of the thinned and
unthinned
vines
and all the growers pretty much thought
they were different they tasted
differently so which one do you prefer
60 said i like the shoot thin
40
said i like the north shoot thin so
that's pretty even thing so i just under
the lines the point that it's really
hard to relate this to
dollars or
willingness to pay for the wine
so
uh okay um
fifth example a shoot thinning trial
turned into a fruit rot trial this was
uh one where i was looking at the impact
of uh shoot thinning and on yield and
quality of uh vignol but it turned out
you know we we turned this into a rot
trial
uh so
here's the vsp with suit thinning no
shoot thinning
high cordon with
shoot thinning or no shoot thinning
and then since this was machine harvest
with long spurs there was a lot of these
persistent racuses from last year a lot
of botrytis
inoculum on those
so we did a trial where we uh
so
so here's the here's what the what the
wines we made out of them look like
uh anyhow so uh wayne went out there and
did the botrytis ratings and uh
and we looked at uh all three scenarios
on the two
two train systems
and uh basically um you know the top
wire cordon that always had more
botrytis
and uh and really was you know it never
got below 50 on that
uh but when we looked at the vsp
you know with none we had a certain
amount if we
uh removed the rakeses we got some
reduction if we shoot then we got more
reduction if we did them both
you know they sort of had this uh
additive effect
and this is what the fruit looked like
you know shoot thin
versus non-shooting
oh
and anna catherine mansfield refused to
make wine out of the stuff on the right
okay so last example here
uh and this is something that uh is sort
of a totally new way of thinking about
managing crop load on concourse because
concords are a commodity crop
and uh in high yield is you know high
yield and low cost that's always been
the objectives that we've been shooting
for
so uh 2013 was a very heavy crop year
and uh
and it was interesting i talked to rich
ertl the director of uh cooperative
extension after excuse me grower
relations at national grape cooperative
and that year a lot of their growers did
mechanical
shoot thinning for the first time or
excuse me cluster things so
fifty percent of our new air kick was 33
of our pennsylvania
acres mechanically thinned in july
and uh as a result they were able to get
eight to nine tons and uh deliver it
early if they didn't then they would
have to wait till the end of the season
and it might not even get ripe
so this is a huge economic
benefit in that one year
and it goes back to foundational uh
concepts of crop load uh done by nelson
charles in the 60s
and then bob poole and terry bates
followed it up with minimal pruning
terry refined it into kind of a system
and then they did lots of demonstration
so the conservative estimate of the
impact was that it was nine million
dollars
uh
in 2013.
uh and just a note here's how they do it
you take your grape harvester out and
you harvest 48 feet of roe that's 1 100
of an acre you weigh the fruit
and then you go to this table
to say well i got this much fruit and
you know basically at the 30 days post
bloom is going to be you know half of
what you're going to end up with at the
end of the season so then they can take
their mechanical harvester out
in
early august and you know thin it and
then hasten the ripening war
avoid delaying the ripening actually
depending on the the growing season so
that's what growers did and uh here's
what happened uh the purple bar is
2013.
left side is uh the ones that thin they
got less yield
the n thin higher yield
and this is from spray record excuse me
harvest weight records
so
when they thinned they kind of evened
out things they got less in 2013 more in
2014.
in the end then they got a lot in 2013
but then they paid for it 2014 with much
much lower yields so
all told you know averaged over several
vineyards it was worth a half a ton
extra fruit
to them
over the two years
and this is a tribute to all the hard
work that the lake erie
uh squad has done
over
many many years to refine these concepts
and
you know it's interesting it's it
we get a lot of press for sort of new
things that we do
but
less it's it's it's harder to come up
with
something that is the result of years
and years of sustained effort that
really finally has an impact hard to
interest the cornell chronicle and that
stuff
um
okay so those are all my examples
and uh
so we have a couple things you know on
the right side is what scientists like
to do right
on the left side is what some of our
funding agencies and
like to do they like the metrics well do
we have metrics for everything
well there are times when we can do what
they suggest
which is you know document how many
growers have done this that or the other
but oftentimes that's hard to do
and and
what are the alternatives well send out
a survey to growers how much nitrogen
you using this year how much
and i hate
doing that because growers hate
doing all those surveys
so
more often than not we're just
reduced to saying things like well
growers report that they're doing
something as a result of our
efforts
and meanwhile i know that
uh our extension programs have had
a huge
extension and research programs have had
a huge impact on the industry
helped
uh
foster its growth development
ecologic and economic sustainability but
sometimes that's just hard to put into
return on investment sort of metrics
so
uh again
this is the thing that uh i've tried to
do
throughout my career is these
collaborative trials kind of the heart
of my extension effort
and uh
and again i believe you know the line
between research and extension is best
if it's kept really really blurry
but
i've managed to
over the course of my career
have the opportunity to work with so
many great faculty members
tax extension qualities
and uh and growers
so
that's it
and thank you for your attention
yeah marvin
you know we're seeing more and more
wineries going and stuff like that but
the numbers you show
make it seem like i don't know if i
would invest my money doing that um so
what do you advise
people to come to you now and say hey
i'm really interested in
certain winery
yeah
well what do i advise people who say
geez i just want to grow grapes and and
have a winery
um
well there's a lot more money in the
value-added part of it than there isn't
the grape
uh
but i've had examples of people uh you
know that come to mind like a guy who
came into my
office in
1997 and
or 1998 and said you know i'm a
pharmacist i want to grow grapes
and
mentally rolled my eyes and you know
said well are you aware of this this and
this
often i try and talk people out of it
because you know that's what you do uh
but you know here
uh 20 years later he has a 50 acre
vineyard loves growing grapes
and made a real success out of it
because
he
did his homework and so forth so
um so i guess telling him uh do your
homework
and uh
i guess a lot of people
uh
uh really repeat the thing how do you
how do you make a small fortune in the
wine industry you start out with a large
portion that sort of thing
uh but then you know i have an another
one boundary breaks vineyard uh again
this is a guy that came in and said
you know
i'm a wine geek i want to make the best
riesling in the world and how many times
have i heard that
over the years how many people have
you know sort of tried to do that
uh
but
but he's successful and now you know has
30 acres of grapes has a wonderful
business
he was very good at marketing very very
intentional about it
so
you can make a success of it
it's just
don't expect it to be easy or don't
expect to
actually be making money uh
uh
until it's you know you're 11 years into
it if you're a winery
and that's just exactly been his his
experiences that you know
he invests a lot of money up front and
then
so finally it's starting to come back to
him in the wine that he sold
i don't know if that's a good answer but
but
yes
so uh kind of
the question in
with two different um
you know audiences one is when you talk
to the grape growers about a practice
that might have
a positive environmental impact but not
necessarily an economic one
how are you talking to them about that
and then the second part is that when
you talk to the funders or work with the
funding agencies
how would you like them to
assess
positive environmental impacts
yeah because you were just mentioned
economics and that they just want to
know yeah
yeah but we know that there's a lot of
positive we do a lot of work and show
positive environmental impacts from our
work how do we compare that back to the
growers and to the funders
uh
well the growers are pretty easy to sell
and uh
on it
actually
uh because you know
a lot of them like if you're on long
island they say god i'm spending way too
much time on my spare how do i get out
of this you know
and that might be new varieties that
might be
something
else um
i don't have any you know bad answers
about this but uh
but it's the growers that have been
pushing us
to do the environmental
impact because they want to publicize
the fact that they use cover crops they
don't do any tillage et cetera et cetera
so you know they're kind of pushing us
in a way
so it's not a hard sell
getting them to think about it
it's more tempting to soft pedal the
parts that are you know
maybe not so great
uh with them
uh with funders i think you just have to
have a narrative that you tell them and
uh
yeah i don't see how we're gonna have
any you know huge
uh
hard metrics that we're gonna be able to
talk about
with with those things i don't know
whatever is just saying congratulations
no questions perspective congratulations
wow nice so so what comes next
what do you think about what comes next
for me yeah i mean you don't look around
but do you have some ideas
yeah well uh
one thing i'm doing right now that i
just started last week is i'm going to
be a vineyard inspector for their
third party sustainability program
from the new york wine grape foundation
and uh
this has been fun
so far because
the last two years with kovid i've spent
most of my time just sitting behind my
computer and writing stuff and not
seeing anybody so now i get to go out
and
you know
talk to people and and find out uh what
what they're doing
and uh it's been interesting just in the
first week i found out you know some
people are doing great stuff some people
are doing terrible stuff in parts of
their
uh
operation you know for example i found a
spray shed that had a bunch of squirrels
living in it
you know at one place and then another
another one where they've gotten 75 cost
sharing from
from
nrcs to build a just a wonderful
spray spray facility so
um so that's one of the things
i like i'd like to stay involved
somewhat with the industry because uh i
have a lot of friends in the industry
and uh and uh
that's really the best part of been the
best part of the job for me
so i don't know what i'm gonna do marvin
but i'm gonna do something
so and elizabeth lamb would like to know
so what advice would you give to an
emerging extension specialist or someone
interested in becoming one okay
um
my impression is
make a good impression in the first two
months
get out and meet meet people
because they always have a long memory
so if they have a bad encounter
that's what they're going to think about
you for the rest of your career
uh one of the keys for me was just
starting in right away with these trials
and uh
and people would see me out there in my
in the car hearts and you know out
collecting stuff
and uh
that's when i realized okay i might not
know how to fill up a sprayer
but
i know how to collect data
analyze it write about it and that's
what they
really value from us so
so that's my other piece of advice is go
out and collect some data generate some
knowledge yourself
and
uh
i guess in my position i never had a
problem
getting faculty collaboration i mean
i i always felt for my colleagues say in
wisconsin or something where they were
all
out there by themselves but here at
cornell we had you know
10 or 11 different programs working on
stuff
and uh
you know i didn't mention it but one of
my most rewarding things the last couple
years have been working with bruce rice
here on the vitus gen project
and uh
it's
you know
and it's just
great to um
and important for somebody in extension
if they're not taking advantage of the
expertise on campus you know
i don't think they're doing their job
thank you very much okay thank you
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu